this 18 year old may become the youngest
world chess champion of all time meet
alireza farrugia already at the age of
12 farouza was making headlines winning
the national championship of his country
iran and playing tens of thousands of
games online soaring up the online
charts and winning masterpieces late in
2021 he surpassed the 2800 rating
barrier a feat accomplished by only 13
other players in history he was the
youngest to ever achieve the mark
farrugia's victory in the riga grand
swiss competing against 100 other grand
masters earned him a spot in the 2022
candidates tournament which will select
a challenger for the reigning world
chess champion magnus carlson world
champion carlson himself has said he is
reluctant to defend his world
championship title against anyone except
for ruja farouja is certainly the
greatest chess prodigy since magnus
himself and that's why